et le travail de reprise de contrôle de
tous les territoires et de réduction des
théories se poursuit tant sans la poche
d'idleb que sur le nord-est du pays
donc il ya une dimension humanitaire
dans tout ce travail est malheureusement
on l'a donnée terroriste sur le terrain
continuent à constituer un problème et
les terroristes cherchent à s'emparer
des biens qui sont fournis dans le cadre
de l'aide humanitaire il les récupère
pour eux mêmes et à genève il ya un
groupe de travail spécialisé sur les
questions monétaires qui travaillent sur
cette question
et petit à petit les tu as réussi à se
rétablir sur l'ensemble du territoire
les conditions du retour des réfugiés se
trouvent plus ou moins réunis mais là
encore il faut une aide internationale
qui puisse être ciblée est organisée
dans ce domaine
[Musique]
on voit de la part des pays occidentaux
une politique de deux poids deux mesures
c'est à dire que certains pays
occidentaux ne veulent pas aider les
syriens mais sont prêts à aider là où le
territoire est sous contrôle de
l'opposition l'opposition parfois
radicales et je pense que le groupe de
travail spécialiste de la question
humanitaire à genève doit s'intéresser à
cet aspect là du problème est la
troisième orientation majeure c'est le
travail qu'il faut poursuivre sur le
processus politique à trouver à établir
pour rétablir la paix et nous apprécions
plus haut point les efforts que vous
faites vous personnellement et avec
votre équipe de façon à restaurer une
atmosphère de dialogue une culture du
dialogue et de confiance
cela est important
il ne faut pas dramatiser le fait que
dans les deux trois mois qui ont suivi
les débuts des travaux du comité
constitutionnel il n'y a pas de
résultats concrets encore obtenu ce
n'était pas non plus notre objectif que
ce soient si rapides mais dans cette
situation évidemment le travail que vous
pouvez faire pour la mise en place de
nouvelles sessions du dialogue politique
là encore c'est pour nous très important
et donc nous avons de quoi parler et
encore une fois bienvenu.merci
[Musique]
j'apprécie beaucoup de russie à moscou
et j'apprécie la coopération étroite que
nous avons établies j'espère que nous
allons poursuivre cette coopération et
attendre de grands succès dans ce
domaine et cela va contribuer à la syrie
je crois qu'il ya au moins trois aspects
de ce processus qui sont importants à il
ya un aspect politique mais il ya aussi
un aspect économique
je pense qu'en ce qui concerne l'aspect
politique nous apprécions beaucoup
l'aide de la russie qui a contribué à
au travail du conte comité
constitutionnel je pense que c'est un
grand pas en avant parce que
l'établissement du de ce comité
constitutionnel c'était la première fois
où les partis ont créé un document écrit
et ce qui est important aussi c'est que
les deux parties se reconnaissent le
l'autre et ce comme ça a été dit je
pense que tout cela est une voie de
travail ensemble de voix de confiance et
de dialogue
nous comprenons bien que cela va prendre
du temps et j'apprécie beaucoup la
contribution de la russie 6 et ses
efforts pour établir ce comité
constitutionnel et que les rencontres
puissent se poursuivre dans un climat de
confiance
c'est un processus qui est complexe qui
petit à petit peu abouti à des résultats
concrets pour la population série en
syrie si vous regardez la situation de
la crise aujourd'hui le problème est
toujours on n'a que 2 50 % plus de 50%
de la population syrienne qui a quitté
ce domicile
donc aujourd'hui on a plus ou moins la
situation dans laquelle ils peuvent
commencer à revenir ya après la poche
des des bâtisses maintient la lutte
contre le terroriste se poursuit mais
malheureusement la population civile a à
payer un prix important et on a sept
cent mille personnes qui sont comme
ils sont quand même revenus mais on a un
à 1500 qui ont été tués c'est un tribut
qui est lourd à payer
donc nous allons poursuivre ces
discussions aujourd'hui sur ce sujet
mais le troisième élément comme
mentionné c'est la situation politique
donc il faut voir si on peut améliorer
cette situation
je suis à rétablissement de la confiance
qui a été qui est celle qui a été notée
petit à petit mais mais je compte bien
sûr sur l'appui de la russie pour
continuer et comme monsieur lavrov l'a
mentionné je serai prochainement aux
discussions et nous allons poursuivre à
travailler sur ce sujet je vous remercie